revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 y Marta Moya está con
nosotros en el estudio Marta bienvenida
buena mañana de martes la semana avance
Y por supuesto también avanzan las
noticias y vamos a abrir nuestra revista
de prensa con la situación política y
social de Irán porque también hay
polémicas en torno al papel del
jugadores de la selección de fútbol que
sigue generando tensiones dentro y fuera
de la fronteras iraníes vamos a comenzar
con algeciras Marta y Raúl buenos días
empezamos con el yasira que hace este
artículo que titula porque es difícil
concentrarse en el fútbol en este
partido entre Estados Unidos de Irán que
van a jugar a las 2 de la tarde hora de
aquí local de Bogotá
destaca este artículo varios aspectos
curiosos de este enfrentamiento también
futbolísticos dice por ejemplo Que si
Irán vence hoy frente a Estados Unidos
sería la primera vez que pasa a la fase
eliminatoria en el Campeonato del mundo
que el primer enfrentamiento en un
mundial entre ambas selecciones en 1998
y que fue la primera vez que Washington
y Teherán se enfrentaban en este evento
deportivo después de que ambas naciones
cortaran sus relaciones después de la
revolución islámica de 1979 en Irán que
entonces los jugadores iraníes
entregaron ramos de rosas blancas a los
jugadores estadounidenses Y ambos
conjuntos deportivos Se tomaron una foto
grupal y ese partido se acabó
convirtiendo Incluso en la primera
victoria de la selección iraní en un
mundial de fútbol en este momento no
parece que vaya a pasar no va a parecer
que vaya a pasar este gesto de
diplomacia entre ambas selecciones tal
como está en las relaciones entre ambos
países destaca también este artículo de
algeciras un poco como está viviendo la
afición iraní el desarrollo de su
selección en esta copa del mundo cuando
perdió contra Inglaterra salieron a
celebrar los manifestantes contra el
régimen iraní cuando Irán ganó contra
gales salieron a celebrar los acérrimos
al gobierno iraní los policías también
se destacan como unos hinchas que van
ondeando banderas desde sus vehículos y
tocando música y también destaca este
artículo que el régimen destacal Line
importancia de utilizar la bandera
nacional y no la pre-revolucionaria que
es la que han utilizado algunos algunas
personas en favor de las protestas sobre
todo ayer Irán presentó una queja ante
la FIFA porque Estados Unidos
había eliminado la palabra a la de la
bandera de la República islámica en
favor de las protestas no y que Irán
sigue acusando a Estados Unidos Raúl de
ser el principal promotor de los
disturbios y el terrorismo en el país
Marta que dice CNN respecto a este tema
Pues destacamos un artículo de la CNN
que dice que irán amenazó a las familias
de la selección nacional de fútbol esto
según cita una fuente de seguridad
vinculada al Mundial de Qatar familiares
habían sido amenazados con y torturas si
los jugadores no se comportan y
comportas comportan es una cita textual
en su partido contra Estados Unidos no
comportarse significaría no cantar el
himno o participar de alguna de las
protestas tras no haber cantado el himno
En el Debut el equipo habría sido
llamado a una reunión con miembros de la
guardia Revolucionaria y decenas de
oficiales habrían sido reclutados para
monitorear a los jugadores que no se
pueden relacionar con otros jugadores de
otras elecciones y por tanto tampoco con
extranjeros además antes del primer
partido el régimen según sostiene esta
fuente a la CNN prometió el equipo
regalar carros y esto Esta promesa se
dirimió después de que no cantaran el
himno nacional bueno Y qué dice el arian
International destacamos un artículo que
dice que un archivo de audio pirateado
revela una preocupación por no detener
los disturbios en Irán esto es un audio
hackeado por el grupo Black reward y
sostiene que
una reunión entre un comandante de la
guardia Revolucionaria y representantes
afiliados a esta institución revelan
preocupaciones por el cansancio de las
fuerzas de seguridad iraníes así como
los paros emitidos provincias iraníes y
la derrota de la guerra mediática del
gobierno iraní también esos tiene estas
revelaciones de este audio hackeado que
los reformistas iraníes se habrían
empezado a reunir con altos mandos del
Estado para intentar buscar una solución
pero Que de momento sin éxito y también
revelan que se habrían distribuido hasta
Diez mil entradas para la copa del mundo
sobre todo para afines a el gobierno
iraní el curry International Marta
destacamos también un artículo que dice
que las ambulancias se han convertido en
una herramienta al servicio de la
represión en Irán que desde el inicio de
las protestas las fuerzas de seguridad
utilizan estas ambulancias para
mezclarse con manifestantes y además
atacarlos y arrestarlos cita una
investigación del New York Times en la
que bueno dice que no son paramédicos
los que asisten estos vehículos
vehículos médicos sino que son agentes
que participan de la represión además
muestra que la presencia de ambulancias
en imágenes entrando y saliendo de
comisarías y las protestas en el sector
de la medicina no se han hecho esperar y
dicen que las ambulancias se tienen que
utilizar para trasladar a los heridos no
Esta técnica se suma a la desconfianza
de manifestantes hacia el personal de la
salud y varios manifestantes heridos
sostienen que después de haber sido
trasladados al hospital fueron incluso
detenidos muy rápidamente Marta que hay
sobre las protestas a contra el gobierno
de chillín por su política de cero covid
del país y de economist Pues el país
dice algunas de las razones no que han
llevado los chinos a las calles sobre
todo el hartazgo después de dos años y
medio de encierro que ha derivado
también un hartazgo económico por las
medidas de Kobe 0 y los hechos que han
pasado en estos últimos 70 días que han
generado tienen mucho revuelo en las
redes sociales muerte de 27 personas
tras volcar un autobús
detención de un hombre en Beijing que
portaba carteles pidiendo el fin de las
restricciones al final también está
huida en masa de los trabajadores de la
fábrica foxcon incluso pues la gota que
colmó el vaso el incendio en la fábrica
dejó 10 muertos y el día economis dice
Queen pues está en su era dulce que ha
confirmado su tercer mandato como
secretario general del partido comunista
pero que china también enfrenta un año
difícil porque las potencias extranjeras
se alían para
poner sanciones a la industria
tecnológica china que la demografía
implica un envejecimiento de la
población y que las consecuencias de las
políticas de cobi 0 también ralentizan
esa economía Así es Marta excesivamente
rápido pero que no se quede por fuera la
cena que tuvo Donald Trump la semana
pasada con líderes abiertamente
antisemitas como lo reseña new
Pues el New York Times dice que los
aliados judíos del partido republicano
han roto o estar intentando romper
relaciones con Donald Trump después de
esta cena porque se reunió con kanye
West y con con nick Fuentes que son
abiertamente antisemita y negacionista
del holocausto y que Donald Trump
debería repensar esta fórmula y la msi
news destaca también un una cita del ex
vicepresidente Mike pence que dice que
Donald Trump no solo debería pedir
perdón sino denunciar a esta gente bueno
Marta Muchísimas gracias por la revista
de prensa de hoy mañana con más